[Music]
hey
here we are everybody again deb's here
so mango's here sandra's here
everybody's here michael's here
andy dom is here pokey's [ __ ] was it
she was in here
she sees us talking to boxes and light
boxes she doesn't know what those are
but it's just it's like oh it's time to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up she runs up here and she
thinks it's all [ __ ] again yeah she's
like i'm gonna
chew on all your mouse cords step on all
the
keyboard yeah jump on top of the [ __ ]
laptops
i've have to like i have i have a spray
bottle in here of like febreze and i
have one of hairspray too because i
don't spray at her
obviously i wouldn't do that but it's
like she doesn't like the noise that a
spray bottle makes just spray bottles
but she knows that it's this pretty
so all you have to do is take it out and
show it to her and she's like fun and
she like she jumps in and runs away
she's like
with a vacuum cleaner let's grab a
vacuum cleaner and she's like fine
although the weird thing is she's not
bothered by the
the shampoo the shampooer no the carpet
cleaner the carpet shampoo
even though that makes a noise too it's
just kind of but
it's just i don't know and they look
kind of the same it's just kind of
it's just the the idea that that thing's
eating the [ __ ] ground
it doesn't make sense from a cat's point
of view why would you do that
why would you run right that's why like
life must be very confusing for a cat
it's like what the hell are these like
two-legged like hairless cats doing why
would you just run that thing around and
have it [ __ ]
yell at the carpet have it yell at the
carpet yeah it's a carpet yeller
yeah i think beijing i think beijing
hates
the vacuum cleaner more than pookie does
yeah i mean beijing
will run in here knock every single
thing over jumping up on my desk and
jumping up and hiding behind the [ __ ]
like way up there by the ceiling
like and she'll just like duck down back
there i've taken pictures of her with a
little eyeballs peeking out lasers can't
[ __ ] believe it
i mean she's up there just totally
indignant just what the
[ __ ] why
[Laughter]
yeah she gets she's very she's very put
out by the but she's yeah she like
[ __ ] flips out
so uh yeah so what are we talking about
today oh okay talk about that program
that show that program what about that
exorcism that movie
it was good you know what i kind of i
kind of loved this movie and
and i don't say that a lot but it's like
so this is called the cleansing hour
yeah it's good and uh it's an exorcism
movie it's on
shutter it's like a shutter original
kind of exclusive kind of i don't know
it's kind of a comedy but it's kind of a
series i mean it has like a lot of comic
elements to it but it's not like
i don't know i don't know if i'd call it
a horror it just took the same they just
took the same concept that was
really cool in the 80s and the 90s where
you got to have a [ __ ] good horror
movie but then they
updated it to social media times
but it's still it's still like
like a low budget crazy [ __ ] flick we
used to watch it's just that it doesn't
look low budget anymore it looks a high
budget
yeah even though this is low budget but
it's like it doesn't look like it don't
look like it anymore
just goes to show you that some of these
streaming services have badass original
content that
back in the day would have been like a
[ __ ] really good
movie that you saw in the theater and
now they can make it you know on a
fraction of the budget
and and the [ __ ] the production is
looking top-notch and
the acting is really good it's about
this movie's a trip
it's about a guy who who's a youtuber
and he's yeah are they live streaming
they live stream
live streams just like in these
paranormal events
well it's an exorcism show he's called
the cleansing hour
yeah and he dresses up like a priest and
he goes out and does these exorcisms
but it's all a hoax yeah they're fake
the sobs don't realize it
but this [ __ ] is badass man he all comes
onto the [ __ ] it's got really good
production
values the music his show does
chanting and [ __ ] almost like a heavy
metal [ __ ] spin
to it i love the intro for his yeah and
he comes on his looking like
young sexy priest in his [ __ ] early
30s he's doing the sexy jesus routine
and [ __ ] you know what i mean he's got
the [ __ ] beard
the bearded stash
[Laughter]
like something ming the merciless would
have he's got his [ __ ] priest rubs
and [ __ ] he takes it off and [ __ ]
and he's uh he's got some good muscle
definition you know his delts and his
abs you know
he's he's he's like i said he's he's in
sexy jesus mode he's
you know he's thin thin and thin with
definition
and of course all the female subs you
know in the movie they [ __ ] love this
dude
throwing hearts at him
fighting demons and [ __ ] well he makes
such a [ __ ] stir
that he attracts the attention of a real
demon
because you knew that that was good
[Laughter]
so he's got to do this possession and he
thinks it's at first he thinks it's fake
no this [ __ ] was [ __ ] real
in fact demons manifest
like they do yeah eventually a demons
met and walked through the room
and the [ __ ] the special effects were
good the story was good
it was good the thing that i like yeah
like i want to see it again i mean
yeah i do too i kept having to leave the
room for [ __ ] [ __ ] i was cooking
something
remember what it was just cooking
something had to keep checking on the
[ __ ] oven
yeah the thing about this like i said
it's you know exorcism movies are like a
dime a dozen
but so i was just kind of like well
another extrasome movie okay but
i liked the angle that they kind of came
at this one from
and also i think what really makes this
movie
is that one it has comedic moments but
it's not like over-the-top zany or
anything like that i liked the social
media aspect
the thing that i think really elevates
this movie is the acting
and the relationships between the
characters particularly against
uh with the the priest quote-unquote
father max yeah he's a fake priest
and yeah he's a fake priest and his best
friend
uh drew who is like his behind the
scenes guy like he's the one that you
know
you know manages the stream and like you
know kind of gets all the crew together
to do the special effects and everything
and these two like they kind of go back
a little bit they do some flashbacks
because they were both like in
uh you know parochial school or whatever
the [ __ ] they call it
catholic school together and uh so
they've been friends since
children and i think they did a really
good job
establishing like the deep friendship
between these two guys
and the the guys are like and they have
like a really complicated relationship
too you can tell they love each other
they're best friends and they've been
best friends since they were kids
they kind of stick stick up for one
another like you know when one got
bullied it's like the other ones stick
up for him and everything
but it's also kind of like complicated
now because
father max is kind of the face of the
show he's the cleansing hour
he's getting all the attention because
he's like all good-looking and foxy and
everything and he's the one that's on
camera
whereas drew is like the one that's
behind the camera he's the one doing all
the work essentially yeah he's like the
tech nerd
yeah and he does take like like more of
the money
but so that's like another kind of point
of contention
so it's it's kind of like interesting
the way they set up like the
relationship between these two
yeah and as the story unfolds the guy
behind the camera turns out
he's [ __ ] really good at what he does
too he saves dude's ass he's
heroic and [ __ ] it's good that's yeah
that's another cool thing is that
everybody
even though they're very flawed
characters and like some of them do some
shitty things or have done some shitty
things in the past
like as the story goes on everyone
really kind of like rises to the
occasion of like [ __ ] that they have to
do to like [ __ ] sort this [ __ ] out
because what ends up happening so so
like i said they have this show and
i don't think it's youtube they don't
mention youtube that's what it's trying
to be but it's kind of like something
or some like live stream type of thing
and it's like this is a very popular
uh show they make they all make a living
at it they have a whole crew they have a
studio they have special effects guys
they have all this kind of [ __ ]
so it's like they're you know they're
pretty successful now
so so basically their shtick is that
every week he comes on
and he does his thing and he exercises
somebody successful
and he sells a bunch of merch like he
has like prayer cloths and all that kind
of stuff
a lot kiss yeah i just thought that was
like super funny too
yeah he has like all this [ __ ] merch
on the side and then it's funny one of
the things that's funny is that they go
to the [ __ ] club
and the [ __ ] the fake priest guy
he gets up on stage and on karaoke night
[ __ ] starts singing [ __ ] heavy
metal ballads and [ __ ] and all the
[ __ ] girls are [ __ ] loving on her
it's just kind of funny [ __ ] that
happens in the movie yeah they're like
you know who that is you know what i
mean and then you're like
he's a famous exorcist and [ __ ] dudes
in the crowd like
what talking about and just showing his
online presence and everything you know
just hilarious you know
that's yeah it is like a very funny like
yeah you know
when you work on social media when you
work in social media it all kind of it's
funny
yeah you know and i like that it wasn't
like i said i think what's good about
this movie because i've seen like a lot
of
horror movies like based around social
media and some of them are good and some
of them not so much
i like that this like it it
it was a big part of the story but it
didn't it wasn't like
over the top and he's like like it
wasn't like wink wink anything like that
it was just like a very organic part of
the story which i thought was good
because some of the ones that i've seen
that are based around a social media
thing
like they lean too hard into um
social media or they're trying to make
some kind of like uh comment about oh
everybody's just like their faces are in
their phones and blah blah blah
it's like there's a little bit of that
in this but i do but they don't like
go over the top no it's just a sign it's
just a side part of the story yeah and
it's
and it does end up like having you know
which is the way it really is when you
work in social media
it's right it's not all your life it's a
side gig yeah it's just like it's
their job it's their job and like they
just get bigger and bigger at it yeah so
what ends up happening they have this
show it's like
successful but they're you know just
like anything else they're trying to
make it more
successful so they're trying to like
drew is kind of like maybe we should
branch out into doing like other
paranormal type things like ghost hunter
type things because this exorcism thing
is a very niche market
and you know father max is like no this
is my shtick i don't want to do that so
there's
like some conflict there so at the
beginning they do it
you know an exorcism and you think it's
a real one but then like you see all the
special effects and [ __ ]
so they have the next one set up and
father max was like oh i want to change
it up this time so he wanted to do
what he wanted a drag queen right yeah
yeah scarlett von [ __ ] that's right
that's right so funny it's just scarlet
vodka
what was the name of it i was [ __ ]
kind of happy they were gonna exercise
the drag queen
and i was like and i forgot the name the
scarlett von cox i think that's what the
name was
yeah i think that's what it was too and
i said i said jenny what's this dude's
name red dick
yeah he said right she's like no scarlet
vodka
so yeah yeah yeah just funny though red
dick
yeah i was like close that's all i could
come up with
crimson [ __ ] would have been funnier but
like yeah what i mean so
so um i guess that's how father max
wants to branch out it's like you know
we can't just like exercise like normal
people or whatever like all the time so
we have to get like we have to keep
up in the stakes so it's like i i found
this drag queen at this club and said
you know she's great and all this other
stuff
so what ends up happening is that
scarlett von kock gets attacked by this
demon that is whose attention has been
drawn by this
show like as it's getting more
successful scarlett von kock gets taken
out
so it so happens that drew's fiancee
has to step in at the last minute
because scarlett boncock doesn't show up
and uh she has to like be the actor like
in the extras and butt it turns out she
gets possessed for real
so i like that they so they like upped
the stakes a lot like so you see you
have this thing with
drew the best friend he's like kind of
feeling like underappreciated
um because he's like you know i don't i
don't get all the chicks like i just
don't get the appreciation because i
like work behind the scenes you know and
and everything so uh but but the fact
that his girlfriend
is now in mortal danger um
and i think it's cool the way that both
the guys
like kind of come together with their
own strengths and they
to like defeat the [ __ ] you know what i
mean now a lot of people get killed i'm
not saying that because they really
don't know what they're doing
because they just know how to do fake
[ __ ] what i liked about the movie
is that the movie kind of
it makes a lot of social commentary but
it doesn't do it directly it's doing it
indirectly
yeah that's what i meant it wasn't real
like you're right it's not preachy or
anything that's not [ __ ] political
but it's also making a lot of
con statements about where we are
in history okay it's talking about
basically what the movie showing is one
the death of the rock star
the death of the movie star okay the
[ __ ] celebrity of the future is
it are guys that are streaming from
their homes
who have star power quality they got
[ __ ] [ __ ] tons of [ __ ] subscribers
and they go to [ __ ] clubs and sing
karaoke
okay yeah which with the log downs the
death of [ __ ] theaters
uh [ __ ] entertainment giants like
[ __ ] disney starting to falter
hollywood going shitty
the this movie is a product of the times
that it's talking about and that's what
i really liked about it
it's giving you excuse
old school good quality writing and
storytelling
but it's talking about very contemporary
[ __ ]
you know i mean it's very much 2020.
yeah
it's talking about a world that's coming
you know
one where celebrities are do it yourself
and that's what i like that's what i
liked about it because that's
the future and it just goes to show too
like the one part where they go to the
bar and they sing karaoke and it's like
these girls are like they're big fans
like they know who they are but
everybody's like who the [ __ ] is that
but it's like they he has like hundreds
of thousands of followers but it's just
kind of like this whole niche little
everything's a niche and and there are
some scenes too where they show like
somebody in israel and somebody in like
korea and something like that and
they're watching them
trying
that's actually what's happening so
that's what i liked is that
it's a it's a a story that's telling
today's reality not yesterdays
yeah that's what i liked about it um
and the movie [ __ ] was a pr and the
movie itself is a product of [ __ ]
shutter
it went straight to streaming yeah on a
small budget
so and the quality of the movie is
really punching way above its [ __ ]
weight
so i just so taking all that into
account i just love this movie i love i
love the way this movie
just you know i like it yeah i mean this
is this is a 2021 movie
basically i mean your mileage may vary
maybe some people i've seen like a
couple
like um because i think this might have
premiered at fantastic fest like la
like in 2019 and then it got purchased
by shutter yeah
um so i've seen a couple of people that
didn't love exilico and other extras in
the movie blah blah
but in general like i think on rotten
tomatoes it's like up in the 80s or 90s
like
um you know positive reviews i have seen
a couple negative reviews of it but
most of them are just like oh you know
it's just doing the same thing again but
i don't really think it was and honestly
you know yes there are a lot of exorcism
movies but
i really liked like i said i think the
heart of this was the relationship
between the two guys
you know what i mean like because the
two guys the two actors in there were so
so good
and you know you really bought their
friendship you cared about them you
didn't want
you you know you didn't want them to get
hurt you didn't want and you wanted to
see them succeed
and you wanted to see them like come to
come together and like you know get
their [ __ ] together
and so i really liked that you were like
rooting for them and i think that's the
best thing that i liked
i liked the movie but i also want to go
meta with it and said i like
what surrounded the outside of the movie
too the meaning of it
yeah it's this is an artifact of the new
coming era
yeah it shows you that you don't you
don't need
a big huge budget to make a res
a fun respectable movie that has
meaning yeah you know that's what i
liked about it yeah i just found this
really really entertaining and it's just
it
talks about how social media is just
kind of [ __ ] woven into the [ __ ]
fabric of
[ __ ] society now there's no escaping
it there's no reverse of it
yeah so it's just the themes that i
liked
yeah you know what i mean that's you
like i said and but you know that
that was good and i like i said i like
that they didn't you know push too hard
on the like you know oh look if we have
a youtube channel or anything it was
just kind of like it was shown as like
a regular job and like they were just
doing it like a regular job like a
regular tv show or whatever
right and um so i should say this was
actually written and directed by uh
damien levesque this is his first
full-length movie um he actually made a
short film
of this back in 2016. so i guess he was
like trying to secure funding to make
like a feature film out of it
and i think he's done a couple other
shorts too but this is his first
full-length
movie which that's pretty impressive
because like i said i see a lot of
horror movies
and i like a lot of horror movies but i
think like after we watched this one i
was like i legit
loved this movie yeah i want to see it
again i'd buy this on blu-ray and add it
to my [ __ ]
material collection i like to have a
physical product yeah
i'd own this yeah i would too yeah i
mean there was just really something
about this one that appealed to me i
think i just really really liked all the
characters it was fun it was
entertaining yeah
um i got really emotionally invested
like in the stakes of it
um there was yeah there was just
something about it that just like really
really appealed
it was a tone i think it was there's the
tone and
careful writing everything yeah it was
it was there back around
came back around later yeah i said that
to you didn't i yes i said everything
that was like set up earlier like came
back yeah it was like really it was a
really tight script it was really like
well written
um but yeah so like i said don't don't
be discouraged
because it's like oh god another
exorcism movie because it really does
kind of go with
a little bit of a different way with it
i mean it's going to have some of the
tropes of an exorcism movie just because
that's
what it is but i like that they did
something new with it they did something
a little more modern with it
and like i said it's just i thought it
was a cool [ __ ] movie so good on you
shutter
and uh you know you uh you ready to wrap
it up just yeah reading what people are
saying
they were mostly it's funny because
they're mostly talking about cats yeah
khan's waiting for the bulger guys to
show up
mango says check out detectives yes i
think you said that to me before i need
to like watch that
that's on shutter as well that's a
series right
because i i'm gonna write it down
because i keep forgetting i have like so
many
things i gotta watch it's like we gotta
um we're gonna do another matinee
tomorrow i wanted to do haunting of
blind manor tomorrow but i haven't uh
had time to finish watching it i think
i'm on the fourth one i think about the
fourth episode
so i still have to finish watching it so
i'll probably review it on wednesday
maybe
yeah so cleansing hour you guys want to
check that one out that's a good one
yeah it's worth watching oh it
definitely is
all right so uh we'll probably need to
wrap this up because i got to
yeah we got we got a [ __ ] heavy
schedule don't you oh yeah i gotta i
gotta record a radio show later and
she's going on the radio tonight and i
got well i think it's recorded i don't
think it's live okay
um and it's all about true crime and i
got like a big list of like
uh you know notes of like true crimes
that i gotta like brush up on so i don't
sound like a [ __ ] when i'm on the show
so i gotta spend the next couple hours
doing that before i go on
so you know all right so we'll see you
guys again tomorrow for another movie
review thanks everybody for stopping by